philsie oh yeah dirty Sasha knock three
Irishmen would never bow down before the
English crown he seems wholesome in the
beginning and that hate his morals
become more and more questionable as the
season goes on and in second season he's
gonna I know he's gonna make some kind
of a deal with a double like character
so I think I think Cyril's gonna
continue to go on a darker and darker
path which is exciting
oh my god you killed a hooker hole girl
she was a zero when they're dead they're
just hookers she caught him cheating
with somebody it was a french maid or
spy I'm not sure
and then he's proceeded to have sex with
other people in the office today
so he's a little lost this guy six two
millimeter Full Metal Jacket someone's
in here yeah season two Cyril Cyril I
think is gonna go to darker places you
know I don't ever get the scripts until
a few days before we actually record
them so I don't I don't know much in
advance
it kind of unfolds as the season goes on
you know I'm crazy
Cyril you're the one who killed a
perfectly good hooker accident when we
got explosive the cops Lana never
forgiven Archer if my life is ruined we
get to do a little improvisation little
ad living I mean description to Archer
are pretty solid to start out with you
know they're really well crafted Adam
rewrites 95% of them I think
you know he has such a good vision of
the show and that world that universe so
he's always open to you know ad-libs and
things and often throws on alts while
we're recording and certainly open to
hearing it for me but I don't I don't
ever come in with like oh I want to try
all this stuff cuz you know I'm there
mostly to just service what he's already
written try to now let's go bury this
dead hooker